[Música]
el Líbano al menos seis personas
perdieron la vida en un tiroteo
registrado en medio de una protesta
convocada por el grupo hezbollah los
ciudadanos se movilizaban para pedir la
destitución del juez a cargo de la
investigación sobre la explosión
ocurrida en agosto de 2020 en beirut
el comité del Congreso de Estados Unidos
que Investiga el ataque al Capitolio del
6 de enero votará el próximo martes para
recomendar cargos penales por desacato
contra el exasesor del entonces
presidente Donald Trump Steve banon
quien se rehusó a asistir a la audiencia
a la que estaba citado ampliamos desde
Washington
un tribunal galo condenó al Estado
francés por incumplir sus compromisos
para luchar en contra del cambio
climático la sentencia incluye la
obligación de reparar las consecuencias
por esa falta de acción con plazo hasta
el 31 de diciembre de 2022
en francés 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos esta misión de
noticias en Líbano donde al menos seis
personas perdieron la vida tras recibir
disparos en medio de una protesta en
beirut la capital del país la
manifestación fue convocada por el grupo
hezbolá para exigir la renuncia del juez
encargado de la investigación sobre la
explosión en el puerto de beirut en 2020
las autoridades señalaron que al menos
nueve personas han sido arrestadas en
relación con el ataque perpetrado por
francotiradores el presidente Michelle
aún aseguró que no permitirá que los
responsables queden impunes
he hablado con las partes implicadas
para abordar lo sucedido y más
importante para asegu de que nunca
vuelva a suceder independientemente de
las circunstancias las fuerzas armadas
cumplieron con su deber y continuarán
haciéndolo manteniendo la seguridad y la
estabilidad civil no permitiremos que
nadie tome el país como rehén de sus
propios intereses el congreso
estadounidense llamó a una nueva
audiencia sobre el ataque al Capitolio
del 6 de enero entre los citados estaba
en el ex jefe de gabinete de la Casa
Blanca Mark middles y el entonces asesor
del ex presidente Donald Trump Steve
vanon quien aseguró que no acatará este
llamado que es de carácter obligatorio
lo que llevó a la comisión de la cámara
que Investiga los hechos a convocar una
votación para el 19 de octubre y
determinar si se adoptan medidas penales
contra banon desde Washington nuestro
corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez nos
explicó más a profundidad que harán los
demócratas y los convocados no asisten a
la audiencia
Exacto ya varios han salido públicamente
varios miembros de este nuevo comité de
esta nueva comisión que Investiga este
caso del 6 de enero a decir públicamente
que van a acudir inmediatamente a la
justicia es decir que este caso se va a
pasar inmediatamente a el departamento
de Justicia para que pues se siga con el
caso y ya varios medios de comunicación
nacional y varios analistas están
diciendo que Steven que es que avino que
pateó y que Mark midus podían incluso
afrontar tiempo en la cárcel si no se
presentan y no acuden a este llamado que
hace el panel de investigación
recordemos que esto es obligatorio Esto
no es una opción cuando el congreso hace
que hace este tipo de llamados las
personas que están solicitadas para
acudir al congreso tienen que
presentarse O tiene que presentar una
excusa válida Y en este caso no tienen
excusa válida lo que pasa entonces es
que al no presentarse pues se abre una
pola se abre una batalla legal y
política aún más grande que profundiza
aún más la polarización que se vive en
este momento en Washington y pues que
muchos críticos dicen favorece a los
republicanos de Cara a las elecciones
legislativas del próximo año recordemos
los hechos del pasado 6 de enero por los
que la comisión del Congreso pide
explicaciones una jornada que marcó la
historia de la capital estadounidense
veamos el informe de Rosa Pérez mateu
nueve meses después El Recuerdo del 6 de
enero de 2021 sigue latente en Estados
Unidos y despierta con cada paso de las
investigaciones judiciales y políticas
que buscan esclarecer el asalto al
Capitolio cuando cientos de personas
intentaron impedir por la fuerza la
ratificación en el senado de los
resultados electorales que llevaron a
Joe biden y a kamala Harris a la casa
blanca
el presidente de Estados Unidos incitó
una insurrección Armada contra Estados
Unidos la profanación del Capitolio que
es el templo de nuestra democracia
estadounidense y la violencia atacando
el congreso son horrores que mancharán
la memoria de nuestra nación para
siempre
de inmediato Nancy pelosi joeyden entre
otros atribuyeron la investigación del
asalto al Entonces todavía presidente
Donald Trump al discurso del odio
repetido durante sus cuatro años de
mandato así como a las palabras que
pronunció ese mismo 6 de enero en un
acto en Washington cuando todavía
denunciaba un supuesto fraude electoral
no nos atrevamos a llamar los
manifestantes eran asaltantes
insurrectos terroristas domésticos así
de simple
y me gustaría poder decir que no
podíamos ver venir pero no es verdad lo
podíamos ver venir los últimos cuatro
años hemos tenido un presidente que ha
desafiado nuestra democracia nuestra
Constitución nuestra justicia de forma
Clara en todos sus actos
a raíz del asalto los demócratas
intentaron un impeachment para evitar
que Trump terminara sus últimas semanas
de mandato no lo consiguieron ahora la
comisión del senado y el departamento de
Justicia buscan la manera de que trami
su círculo rindan cuentas
Hablamos ahora de la atención generada a
nivel global por las fallas o
interrupciones en las cadenas de
suministro que están provocando aumentos
en los precios de numerosos productos
para los consumidores y generando
dificultades para la recuperación de la
economía tras la pandemia de Kobe 19
expertos señalan que la situación podría
empeorar en las próximas semanas
previamente conversamos con Ricardo
Ernest profesor de operaciones y
logística global de la Universidad de
Georgetown quien nos explican que
consisten las interrupciones y Qué
productos principalmente se han visto
afectados
bueno la gran mayoría Recuerda que el
mundo entero tiene un flujo de productos
que va desde china hasta Europa pasando
por los Estados Unidos todo es un flujo
continuo de productos lo que está
sucediendo es que hay un bloqueo O sea
hay una una faltante muy grande de
contenedores todos los productos se
mueven por contenedores déjame darte la
siguiente estadística el 90%. el 90% de
todo lo que se mueve en el mundo se
mueve a través de barco por mar Entonces
cuando tienes estas trabas estos cuellos
de botella tan grandes y la falta de
contenedores puedes Definitivamente hay
una ruptura en las cadenas de
abastecimiento que es lo que está
generando este problema en otras
noticias el tribunal administrativo de
París condenó al Estado francés por
incumplir sus propios compromisos en la
lucha contra el cambio climático y le
dio plazo hasta el 31 de diciembre de
2022 para reparar el perjuicio ecológico
que ha causado la demanda fue presentada
en 2019 con el apoyo de 2,3 millones de
firmas el informes de Aurora bayud
en Francia la justicia se está
convirtiendo en un Aliado del movimiento
climático los tribunales ordenaron este
jueves al Estado que repare las
consecuencias por sus compromisos
incumplidos en materia de reducción de
las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero
se trata de una jurisprudencia histórica
que abre una nueva era para la política
climática en Francia ya que con esta
sentencia los dirigentes políticos se
ven obligados a respetar los compromisos
climáticos asumidos por Francia
el edificio había sido llevado ante el
tribunal administrativo de París en 2019
por cuatro ong bajo el lema el caso del
siglo respaldado por una petición de más
de 2.3 millones de ciudadanos
denunciaban las deficiencias del estado
en la lucha contra el calentamiento
global durante el período comprendido
entre 2015 y 2018
dos millones de personas firmaron Para
demandar al Estado francés por inacción
climática Francia hasta finales de 2022
para reparar los daños sin embargo la
sentencia deja discreción del gobierno
la elección de las medidas a tomar para
hacerlo y rechazar la petición de las
ong de una sanción económica de 78
millones de euros por cada semestre de
retraso
el tribunal da hasta el 31 de diciembre
de 2022 Y eso va más allá de la campaña
presidencial eso significa que es
vinculante para el gobierno actual que
tiene seis meses para publicar decretos
y hacer cosas y también es vinculante
para los candidatos a las elecciones
presidenciales
el gobierno francés tomó nota de la
decisión afirmando ser plenamente
consciente de sus obligaciones y de la
necesidad de seguir acelerando sus
esfuerzos contra la crisis climática la
compañía tesla abrirá en Alemania su
primera mega fábrica en Europa antes de
que termine el 2021 al menos dos años
llevó la construcción de la planta que
generaría un impulso a la economía local
Allí se construi medio millón de
vehículos eléctricos cada año y se
crearán miles de puestos de trabajo pero
no todos están felices con la llegada de
la empresa los ambientalistas locales
critican la tala de árboles y la caída
del nivel de agua veamos más detalles en
el informe
la meta final está a la vista para tesla
El fabricante de automóviles
estadounidense comenzó a construir su
fábrica cerca de Berlín hace dos años y
está por concluirla Albert schooler le
siguió el paso
Cooler es fotógrafo aficionado creció en
la región en su cuenta de Twitter donde
habla de tesla tiene seguidores de todo
el mundo
es una gran oportunidad para la región
pero también para los jóvenes que viven
aquí y que ya no tendrán que irse para
encontrar un buen trabajo el jefe de
tesla en un musk prometió que se crearán
unos 12.000 puestos de trabajo también
agradeció a los lugareños en alemán
Gracias a todos los que han apoyado
nuestro proyecto esta fiesta es para
ustedes
a principios de octubre algunas personas
se les permitió entrar a la planta de
tesla para verla de cerca pero no todos
los locales están entusiasmados con la
llegada de la compañía
en las puertas de la empresa un grupo
predice El impacto ambiental que esta
traería
la fábrica está justo en medio de un
área de protección del agua es una
catástrofe para el medio ambiente local
si surge un problema en la fábrica el
nivel freático se contaminará Y eso
afectará también a ciertos barrios de
Berlín
pero en brandemburgo donde la industria
se ha extinguido en gran medida la
llegada de tesla promete un futuro mejor
los políticos locales la apoyan desde la
reunificación y así Durante los últimos
30 años ninguna empresa que cotiza en
bolsa se ha instalado en el este de
Alemania así que tesla busca echar
raíces y es un momento muy importante
para la región
[Música]
según elon musk el primer tesla
fabricado en Alemania debería salir en
noviembre y sería el primero de 10.000
semanales
y con el vuelo calleri Roma concluyó la
historia de la aerolínea italiana
alitalia un símbolo mundial que operó
durante 74 años la compañía tuvo que
transformarse tras varios rescates que
no consiguieron sacar la flote y nacerá
una nueva compañía aérea totalmente
Estatal con una flota de 52 aviones y
que solo contratará a 3000 de los 11.000
antiguos empleados ahora el estado se
hace cargo de esta aerolínea que pasa a
llamarse Italia transporte aéreo y que
garantizará los primeros vuelos
imprescindibles para las conexiones en
el país
y la canciller de Alemania Angela Merkel
recibió el premio europeo Carlos V de
manos del rey de España como un
reconocimiento a su compromiso con la
unidad de Europa la funcionaria que
dejará la cancillería en cuanto se forma
un nuevo gobierno en Alemania seguro que
es necesario frenar lo que calificó de
fuerza centrífugas existentes en algunos
países europeos para evitar que el
bloque tenga más problemas
a continuación hacemos un repaso por
otros hechos relacionados con el
coronavirus que son noticia en el mundo
Rusia registró 986 muertes y 31.299
contagios de Kobe 19 en las últimas 24
horas nuevos máximos diarios desde el
comienzo de la pandemia
Moscú sigue siendo el principal foco
pero sea registrado un incremento de la
incidencia del coronavirus en 77 de las
85 regiones del país
Naciones Unidas aseguró que la
prolongación de la pandemia ha dejado en
evidencia la necesidad de transformar
los sistemas de salud de latinoamérica
la región más desigual del mundo y donde
el proceso de vacunación avanza de
manera asimétrica
el presidente Joe biden Indicó que
Estados Unidos está preparado para
vacunar a los niños entre 5 y 11 años en
cuanto haya luz verde de las autoridades
competentes el mandatario aseguró que se
tomará una decisión al respecto en las
próximas semanas
y el famoso graffiti del artista banksy
con una niña y un globo en forma de
corazón fue revendido por 25,4 millones
de dólares en una subasta en un nuevo
récord para el británico cuya identidad
sigue siendo un misterio la obra es
reconocida por haber sido destruida
parcialmente por una trituradora
escondida en el marco tras haber sido
vendida en una subasta hace tres años
hoy había máxima expectativa ante una
posible repetición del truco pero la
obra salió sana y salva
y antes de despedirnos los invitamos a
que no se pierdan nuestra entrevista en
exclusiva con la ganadora del premio
Nobel de paz 2021 la periodista filipina
María reza hoy a las 20 horas 45 hora de
Bogotá quito y Lima
llegamos así al final de esta emisión de
noticias pero recuerden que Pueden
repetir esta y otras emisiones y ampliar
toda la información en nuestra página
web Franz 24.com también los invitamos a
continuar con nosotros Porque hay más
aquí en France 24
[Música]